thank you for joining us at noon i'm  john langler we are just one step away  from getting a coronavirus vaccine into  the american public  the fda could authorize the medicine  from drug maker pfizer today  hospitals nationwide are preparing to  receive the first shipments of the  vaccine as early as this weekend  rita shane she is chief pharmacy officer  over at cedars-sinai in los angeles  she says reports of those allergic  reactions in the uk  well that reaction she says is a concern  allergic reactions are something that do  occur with everything we take even food  and the allergic reactions aren't as  concerning as getting covet and so the  focus is on  keeping us safe the fda does want pfizer  to do some studies on those allergic  reactions  the vaccines will come with a warning  for people who have serious  allergies